the Port of Los Angeles isn't just ships
in cargo it's a city within a city like
any community it needs to be protected
and this is the jurisdiction of the Port
of Los Angeles Police Squad detective
Michael below and don't Los Angeles port
Police for two and a half years where a
water-base Police Department however we
also have land responsibility it's very
unique because we're the poor Polly
sitting ok the port's could stay in the
court but no we actually go out all over
the place a lot of my investigations
lead into different areas different
police jurisdictions from drug
trafficking you have a cocaine tested to
truancy is supposed to be in school
right now so he is going to be arrested
for truancy and take it back to school
with a ticket to searching the depths
with the port police dive team
bellows duties take him everywhere in
and around the pork and today it's at a
marina where he's heavily involved in a
case we got called out here last night
for a rape that occurred on a vessel so
basically right now I'm setting up for
the crime scene we just obtained a
search warrant to search the crime scene
itself which is a 53-foot vessel whether
you rape allegedly happened this marine
is kind of far back out of the way from
society people can live out here and
never say nothing to anyone and just
hide so that's kind of why we get our
share of sex offenders down here the
alleged suspect a 53 year old male who
lives on his boat was arrested last
night and put in jail he claims the sex
was consensual but there's a question
whether the alleged victim is able to
give consent the victim was a 21 year
old female but she has a mental capacity
of approximately a 10 year old child
Jeffrey lo arrives from the LAPD's
scientific investigation division to
look for and collect evidence this is
the criminalist from Los Angeles Police
Department basically he's gonna come
process the crime scene for any physical
evidence that is both visible and not
visible to the eye he's equivalent to to
the popular si si lo heads down to the
ship's cabin to investigate
this is for blunt it's just going to do
a general swamp rapine during their
investigation below find something that
could change the direction of this case
childlike drawings depicting a cartoon
man and woman holding hands with the
name of the suspect and alleged victim
okay yeah there's some drawings here
they look like my daughter Giants and it
says like cranson princess you know and
it says from and it appears that she's
drawing this stuff this kind of
cooperates his statement it's pretty
disturbing